the tree here is in that little baby
honey
so that sweetens it so just start off
with 200 mil of delicious honey into a
pan just to warm up and she goes now I
know these are a chef's favorite but it
makes all the difference especially for
breakfast a fresh vanilla pod and I
think of the way that I use herbes to
add flavor to soups and salads and like
the thing that vanilla does exactly the
same scrape out all those wonderful
seeds in now the staple of the granola
yokes
[Music]
next puff rice delicious crunchy was
light and fluffy next add wheat bran and
your seeds pumpkin sunflower and linseed
and and then almonds incredible that
nice heavy weight from the nut Bunch
now bring the honey to the ball slowly
drizzle amazing honey in give that a
really good mix coat the granola with
the hot honey just slowly turn it using
the outside of the bowl you can see it
just getting nice and sticky
once the granola is completely coated in
honey is ready to bake now spread the
mix on baking paper I'm gonna season it
lightly with a touch of salt on top the
salt throughout dries up the oats and
the honey will roast color and glaze
their granola nice into the oven for 25
to 30 minutes
[Music]
ten minutes into the cooking simply run
a spoon across the top to turn the mix
and ensure its crunchy all over you
smell that light's rose look at the
color honestly look it's crispy
delicious now I'm gonna start up and put
some lovely dried cranberries that just
gives us chewy sweet flavor delicious
and then finally these beautiful berries
goji berries goji berries are high in
antioxidants and have been eaten China
for centuries for their healing
properties but you can add any dried
fruit you like for cranberries and the
goji berries gives it that nice chewy
rich texture to the granola now this is
the best way to store it it looks
incredible really incredible man eat
well stay well right milk
my homemade crunchy granola it looks
good tastes good and it's packed with
healthy grains superfood berries and
seeds it's incredibly good for you to
have breakfast for champions
[Music]